je vous le dis je suis à has-been total
et toi aussi
terminé
apparemment la nouvelle mode maintenant
pour les mecs c'est le rasage à la cire
jamais Siri toi et moi jamais de la vie
on rase notre barre c'est un peu je te
dise si je me rase la barbe tu me bouffe
le cul
[Applaudissements]
finalement il faut quand même suivre les
tendances
je me rase la barbe moi frère je vais en
contrôle d'histoire-géo on dirait que
j'ai 12 ans
frère je rentre pas au casino
je vais faire une épilation définitive
de tout
sauf le et je vais juste laisser juste
laisser un espèce
de vidéo
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
regardez la nouvelle tendance
alors il y a une deuxième vidéo elle est
encore plus dure incroyable je peux la
regarder 200 fois regarder elle fait
encore plus mal
c'est la nouvelle tendance qui pourrait
le faire ça moi j'ai déjà fait dans le
nez
parfois ils ont des poils de Zen
[Applaudissements]
il avait une pâte ici
il avait une pénale à rabiata qui était
passé frère sur la tête de ma mère
arrêtez je dis frère tu as un mikado
c'est pour les virus dans le nez les
poils de la bouche pour les virus de la
bouche les poils dans les oreilles pour
les virus des oreilles
alors je me disais qui va le dire
je voulais pas aller au bout
d'une explication la réponse c'est qu'il
y a une situation à chaque fois et là
les poils qu'on voit là ce qui est
vachement dangereux c'est que
généralement on peut arracher facilement
arracher la peau bah oui j'avais une
copine qui travaillait au comptoir des
hommes dans Paris et le maintien est
extrêmement important
le matin chez l'homme parce que ça peut
arracher toute la pauvre
de faire à la cire la
barbec
vous pouvez vous raser si vous voulez
plus de barres pourquoi se faire la cire
mais je vous dis ça c'est la grosse
grosse tendance c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment tendance à quoi ça c'est pas
définitif avec la cire si non
mais non c'est en plus c'est con parce
que pour que ça je vous rappelle c'est
une belle connerie
c'est important